I see you did all the kind of backstory
work for the walking dead by looking at
the comic books and stuff and obviously
quite books are such a huge part of the
world now aren't they on TV and on the
big screen as well
I mean would you like to be involved in
something that was like a straight
superhero story we're all in a comic
book
oh yeah you know um yeah I'd love to I'd
absolutely love to just because you know
I think what's happening now that's
really interesting are the type of
actors who are kind of taking on those
roles at this point you know you have
these really kind of character II actors
who are just taking it to a whole nother
place in the whole nother level so that
yeah I mean I would love to love to kind
of do it outside of that world and
inside of that world as well the kind of
current does it speak to you out of the
comic books that you think I'd love to
see them on the big screen I would love
to be that character um I mean there's
some in particular so that I you know
can't necessarily talk about because I
know it's still kind of up in the air
um but yeah you know there aren't many
young black comic-book superheroes um so
I'd love to take huh I don't know what
you're talking about
but ya know it's great to see static
shock is happening with Jaden and we'll
see what happens
you know we're would--we Marvel decides
to go with spider-man but um yeah I'd
love to take a turn with somebody who
isn't you know that's kind of ethnically
ambiguous and just kind of turn it on
its head and you know force people to
see them in a different light there are
quite a lot of people when the rumors of
another spider-man reboot going on to
Twitter and getting quite excited about
sort of suggesting that you should be
annexed by demand how did you kind of
initially react to that um that kind of
followed the Miles Morales character
quite a bit my brother really did so he
had kind of suggested like if it goes
that way it could work um and you know
I'm open to the idea I am you know I
don't I'm not like starting campaigns or
anything for it
because you know I trust Marvel I've
read for them before so I trust you know
what their decisions will be but yeah I
would love to do it I would absolutely
love to do it I think there's you know a
few names in the Hat that absolutely do
make sense just be you know kind of
who's the best for it but um yeah I'm I
would be stoked to do it I wants to do
what you take would be on Morales if you
got that wrong what would you love to
bring of yourself to the screen my
character that's like evinced um I love
that aspect that he's Dominican and I
grew up around a lot of Dominicans and
Washington Heights um so I'd want to
bring a lot of Washington Heights to him
you know I think you know Myles is
somebody that my people it's a good lot
of confusion that people have of like
black and Dominican is the same thing
it's not necessarily so he should be
bilingual in my mind you know you should
be able to flow in and out and just kind
of bring that aspect of the culture with
him you know he's like kind of this fast
talking smart kid and you know these you
can do that you know
the generic way or you can do it very
specifically and there's something about
that culture to me that does that so
well would you be disappointed if Marvel
decided not to go with the Morales
instead of yeah you know I'd be
disappointed simply because I think it'd
be a nice turn they could be you know
cool think we've seen Peter done so many
different ways um but you know I think
anything at this point you know they're
cranking them out and they're cranking
out hits so if they decide not to go
that way it's for a reason but then you
think that Black Panther 2018 presently
but don't you think that the wanes of
2018 can't you release a superhero movie
that happens to be black and so I'm
still pushing forward and so instead of
doing something now what is all I say
you know we'll definitely see him
earlier um you know in the way they're
modeled by get their cameo things like
the rumors of Civil War and all that
we'll see him earlier um but ya know I
think it's about time you know it's
about time there
right many of them written you know back
in the day anyway so it's definitely
about time yes I think that's twofold
for me I think one I would love to see
it now but two I would hate to see it
not done right because it's rushed so
I'd rather take the wait um and see it
done right and allowing the kind of
stand on his own two feet and that's
working to chadwick and he's gonna you
know he's gonna do a fantastic job with
it but yeah I want to see it I'd really
developed well you know so we don't have
a you know green lantern situation what
are your thoughts on netflix is a Luke
Cage so I capture oh that's going to be
great I think that's you know that's
Luke Kay is I think it's just really I
think she's like Luke Cage and Black
Panther and things like one other um
I've always loved Luke Cage always
thought that was you know great I was
never big enough to actually contend for
him that was always a disappointment but
um I think that's going to be great you
know and I think what's happening now
that's really interesting is we're
seeing multi-platforms for these types
of things which is cool which is you
know I think Luke Cage isn't necessarily
a character that warranted you know a
standalone film however putting them in
the series is absolutely great so we
still see that character Marvel's
allowing you know to give characters
that wouldn't necessarily have gotten
their own film their own world you know
that's what's great that's I really
think it's smart of them a very quick I
just wanted to ask also that you'll take
on kind of colorblind casting in the
superhero world they give things like
Suicide Squad with Will Smith and
fantastic cool I think it's fantastic
I mean I think it's great I think you
know that's the way it should be going
in the right direction I think by making
things more diverse sexually and
ethnically it doesn't hurt any situation
it just doesn't I don't see how it could
by putting more of your audience on the
screen ultimately you know I just kind
of got into the female Thor con because
like this could be fantastic like this I
would love to see this on film of like
you know I think it's one thing that's
been trying to do so well they've been
trying to do but it hasn't like really
been pulled off as well
like now they're just kind of getting
into like Wonder Woman and all these
other things look like maybe that's not
the answer
maybe spider-man's a chick like maybe
that's the answer you know that's it
Neil whether trying to go keep that
specific why don't you just cross it
over you know what's a female Batman
you